Netflix when house of cards came to
Kevin Spacey and the producers came to
him with the idea of house of cards they
said we will give you a commitment
without doing what every other TV
network does which is insist on seeing a
pilot testing it and letting it compete
against others we will give you a
two-season commitment not just a one
season commitment which only very few
get a full season commitment will give
you a two season commitment and so
people said how would they dare risk a
two season commitment without seeing a
pilot without you know without testing
it where people missed which is
something that they miss what Netflix
actually did what Netflix actually did
before Kevin Spacey and the producers
Kant and David Fincher came to them they
looked up and they saw Kevin Spacey
movies did very well on Netflix
David Fincher movies that he directed
did very well political dramas did very
well on Netflix they had a built-in
audience for all of those three and and
the British series that ran earlier in
house of cards had had a lot of
popularity on Netflix or Netflix was
saying if we could combine those four
audience's together we've got a show
that's going to do very well
particularly when you've got Kevin
Spacey fronting it you know as an actor
it was not a sure bet nothing ever is a
sure bet but it was not a blind bet they
knew what they were doing it helped
build up the subscriber base for Netflix
Netflix now has 43 or so million
subscribers around the world and and
that's grown exponentially since they
put on original programming like house
of cards Reed Hastings is an engineer
that's what you have to know and and and
that's an advantage in that in the world
of massaging data and understanding who
your audience is so they come up with
all these different algorithms with the
many engineers who work at Netflix and
they basically slice and dice the salami
in so many different ways to say let let
us test what people liked I mean how
many people like political dramas how
many
you know whatever but the 49,000 I don't
even know all the 49,000 but as I'm
talking to the people who run
engineering for them and they're talking
about how they test their testing
everything what have you watched before
I mean how what is the average amount of
hours you spend binging what what do you
watch after you binge on a political
show what else do you watch you watch
another political show and if you do
then I know I've got a real someone who
really is as a prime customer for me
political show when you watch Kevin
Spacey have you watched all of his
movies and they could measure they have
the data to tell you that that you're
not you didn't just watch watch one
Kevin Spacey movie watch all of his
movies my gosh that's you're a fan I so
they can dice and slice all of that up
and basically present a prediction as to
who the audience is and how big that
audience will be and all might be and
and that becomes a great advantage that
data